I wonder if he even thought that far
like if this guy's smart enough for this
Heist but the last moment he's like I'm
just gonna weather dub and I'm like oh
man
[Music]
so are you guys familiar with the DB
Cooper case
still unsolved right on November 24th
1971 a man calling himself Dan Cooper he
goes to a Portland Airport he gets on an
airplane back then you just get on a
plane you can even pay to be on the
plane while you're on the plane right
it's [__] crazy
um and he used cash to buy a one-way
ticket on flight 305 down for Seattle
shortly after the flight takes off he
slips the stewardess a note saying that
he has a bombers briefcase and he
demands that she writes down what he
told her to the stewardess made her way
to the captain's cabin with with a new
note that that she had written which
demanded four parachutes and two hundred
thousand dollars in twenty dollar bills
when the flight landed in Seattle he
then exchanged the hostages all the
flights 36 passengers for money and
parachutes and then he kept the crew and
the plane took off again and he's like
yo take me to Mexico
somewhere between Seattle and Reno
Nevada a little after 8 pm he opens the
back of the plane puts a parachute on
jumps out with the ransom money and
nobody [__] ever saw him again
crazy that's the minute 30 summation of
the case so there's been a lot of
research about this case a lot of
thoughts about who's behind it they they
found cash over the years like in in
Lake beds like because where he the the
the acreage of where he could have
jumped out is like a lot of wetlands and
a lot of people are like man he probably
just died like like some investigators
just determined that there's no way he
could survive that night it was it was
stormy it was cold as [__]
there was so much rain he could have
like just died like landing on a tree or
something he could just be hanging up in
a tree somewhere like where nobody's
ever found them right
but the mystery just took a turn oh
did they find those dollars that
in circulation that he stole I wish oh
they found a necktie
the black tie that belonged to him that
he left on the plane they did some
analysis on and they found three what
they call important particles that are
significant and there is something that
they can maybe amount to a DNA pattern
that points to a specific company and a
very specific division within the
company at a specific time what company
so he he analyzed these lab reports
right
and it shows like a bunch of different
metal particles on the tie and he was
able to match that up with a
Pennsylvania Metal Manufacturing company
that was operational at the same time
and that had special patents on those
specific metals and alleys that were
found oh so that was the identifier
exactly so they think that he worked
there exactly so they he contacted the
company and he looked into employees who
worked there in the 60s and 70s and then
went to Pittsburgh where the company was
based and then he narrowed it down to
about eight researchers who were working
on those specific metal projects at the
time and then they disappeared which one
disappeared
um well that's that's kind of what they
um you know it it you can't get an exact
story of who the who at the time right
because there's so many different people
that were working at this place but what
he determined is that talking with a
retired company manager
um he said that there was an employee
named Vince Peterson that kind of fit
the bill for what happened time that DB
Cooper made his his jump and this was
like a national news story at the time
um and he was also somebody oddly enough
who regularly traveled to the Pacific
Northwest on business where D.B Cooper
is was jumped out right
um but this guy died in 2002 and then
they interviewed his family and then his
son is like I don't think my dad's TV
Cooper but who knows if his son's like
sitting on cash but the cash has never
been found to be used in circulation
like they had those bills and they they
marked the bills so they know if they
were going to be used I've been obsessed
with the story for years
um so did so so he went back to work and
he's still alive well no he this
particular Trail went to this guy named
Peterson who died in 2002. yeah but but
this Peterson guy yeah
if he was DB Cooper he just went back to
work as usual so in this story if that
was he didn't get lost in the forest he
he went back to work as a researcher he
has children all that stuff that's a
really good question and they don't say
that he went back to work they just said
that he worked there oh okay yeah
because that would be the best mask I
guess is like to just continue life as
normal yeah for sure after you do your
Heist chill out for a minute
then maybe you watch the cash in other
in other ways yeah how would he watch
the cat yeah that's my question
internationally okay really but I mean
at the same time that's a lot of cash to
watch especially I mean what 200 000 in
20s yeah 20 but at what was that the 60s
uh what did I just say at the beginning
71. so that might be like a mill now
it just depends because back then
there's like it's all paper right so
like it really depends on like how well
their tracking was and if if it would
flag anything because of the the cash
came from where yeah yeah so they're
wondering too because it was a it was
like heavy like the briefcase thing I
was heavy so they're wondering too of
when he jumped out like that night it
was like
um well it depends on exactly where
because they they don't exactly know
where he fell obviously because you know
once he's out of the plane he could have
positioned himself wherever with a
parachute
um but they believe that the elevation
um they don't even know exactly what the
elevation was where he landed but the
weather was so rough and there was
steady snowfall for the for four days
afterwards so whatever his path out of
this thing was it was brutal and then
he's carrying a [__] on a cash he must
have had a really strategic plan to keep
himself safe yeah or to bury the cash
and then yeah and then I wonder if he
even and thought that far like if this
guy is smart enough for this Heist but
the last moment he's like jump and I'm
like oh man it's snowing
it's snowing yeah you don't know so what
do you think Steve
um well okay so there's the part of my
brain that just wants him to have made
it out there and he's like it's gonna be
somewhere he's like put that somewhere
else put that somewhere else so I think
that um
because the cash never made in
circulation
ever like they found some in a lake bed
a couple of times like there's a kid
who's like playing one day like I want
to say like 15 years later and they
found some of the cash and they were
able to identify it as the bills from
some of the bills from the DB Cooper
incident so that makes me think that you
know maybe he died and the money was
scattered around yeah
um
and maybe he's like in a tree somewhere
and like just the money because because
of where the Lakes were they were able
to trace it like Okay so this probably
came down this stream here and then like
found its way to this Lake to this to
this side of this riverbed and after the
kid found it so so maybe he died
somewhere upstream and then you know the
cash just fell and yeah scattered yeah I
think he died I think he died after like
jumping out odds are odds are highly in
favor that he just died yeah especially
if he has no survival skills
yeah well it was his first time
parachuting well there's a lot of
there's a there's a lot of theories that
he was ex-military because of the way
that he talked and the way that he was
dressed and the way that um he asked for
the specific parachutes like he kind of
knew what he was doing with that there
was some kind of preparation that went
into it then he must have known you know
what I mean
um well I guess how was like weather
forecasting back then
today
but it's just such a weird thing that if
if he died then that means whatever life
he left behind wasn't looking for him so
that's kind of weird yeah well and the
thought too is okay so if he ends up if
he jumps out ends up in higher
elevations he fell into a snowstorm if
he landed lower elevations he's going
through a rainstorm so like there's a
huge difference in survivability right
there
um he was also just wearing regular
shoes in a business suit when he jumped
out he didn't have like a park on or
survival gear like he's just [__]
wearing isn't that the funniest curse
though like you you get away with this
money and then you die because you just
didn't plan and you're in a shitty
weather condition I know dude and he
jumped out it's cold as [__] he's
[__] dripping there's no way he's not
like Covered in Rain water right and
then um
um never seen again how do you get out
of there with dress shoes on like I
don't know dude and on top of that like
the first thing you probably do is just
hide the cash to get it later yeah if
it's heavy enough yeah figure out a way
to find shelter but then
you run the risk of someone calling the
cops yeah did any of you guys see the
documentary that's out right now on it
I've seen a bunch of them I don't know
if I've seen the most recently there's
like a newest one that really has
awesome real suspects that they were
really like
like some of the people at the lead of
investigative reporting of it now that
are like obsessed like they're crazy
people over this case they've like
determined who they really believe it is
and sometimes it's like a living guy and
yeah they found a guy that like fit all
of the everything you could think of
except for like a couple timeline things
and that guy was declining on um
admitting whether or not he was and then
he died before they could finish the I
know you're talking about yeah and then
uh the crazy thing is uh yeah they think
he was like definitely military that he
was prepared that
um yeah the way that he spoke the things
that he asked for it doesn't seem like a
guy that would jump out and not have a
plan yeah
um especially where he jumped out
exactly yeah or a guy that was so
calculated to make people assume that
he would die you know what I mean sure
yeah and he didn't make mistakes leading
up to when there was no Trace so it's
not like he could have had a cabin or
something ready
or another team like that were waiting
like an extraction yeah yeah it's it's
likely that's what a lot of people think
that was part of one of the
documentaries because you think he knew
where he was like coordinates wise and
then he's like all right now this is
around the area that I'm gonna jump well
he knew where he was taking off right
and he knew where he wanted the plane
pointed towards and heading towards
before he made his jump and then he just
randomly opens the door and jumps out so
I don't think he just does that right he
knew he's being tailed obviously yeah
so I think he used the cover of the
storm to like make sure that the tail
didn't see him get out because they
didn't see him get out
there's just something like in terms of
the timeline and the evidence of what he
did once you can't see him anymore
there's no telling what he did so that's
why it's hard to find like
so far it's like Flawless so it's like
why would he start making mistakes once
you can't see him the biggest mistake of
all yeah exactly so it's sort of like
odds are that he's dead of course those
are the odds but then everything he did
the odds were against him and he still
won so it's like damn man what did he do
the fact that they never found it like
him like is wild to me and there's a
there's also a thing that you would
probably like Joe is that they think he
was connected to the feds in some way
wow because there there was a guy that
was a suspect who used to do uh he did
government work for feds I think he was
like trafficking certain things for Feds
that couldn't do it themselves and they
thought it was him because they were
like oh the reason they don't want to
pursue him is because he's too connected
to something that like he knows
something that he could kind of come out
with so it's not that they can't find
him it's that they won't find him
there's that there's that and maybe they
did and he killed him yeah because of
course it's not an average guy so
they're like oh he might have been
somebody that was like in between the
feds and something bad and they were
like I just let him [__] go there's
only 200 Grand to them yeah I've never
seen a case like this where there's
constantly little breaks in it like
where it's like like me and Nikki did a
podcast about this years ago and that
was like the most uppermost information
and then today it's like holy [__] they
found this tire with these particles on
it it's like there there's such an
interest in it still it's such an active
investigation for being so old because
there's just so much imagination behind
it yeah that I think that would be the
next odds like dead and then the next
one is that he's too well connected that
they're just not gonna find it it's just
not a thing they want to know right
damn could be that too that's cool it is
really cool case of DB kuba
[Music]